as expected wyoming representative liz
chaney lost her bid to remain in
congress by a wide margin
chaney became former president donald
trump's republican nemesis as vice chair
of the january 6th committee
in a forceful concession speech chaney
once again castigated the former
president
two years ago i won this primary with 73
percent of the vote
i could easily have done the same again
the path was clear
but it would have required that i go
along with president trump's lie about
the 2020 election
it would have required that i enable his
ongoing efforts to unravel our
democratic system and attack the
foundations of our republic
that was a path i could not and would
not take
cheney's opponent lawyer harriet hageman
was endorsed by trump who is very
popular in wyoming trump congratulated
hageman and called cheney spiteful
obviously we're all very grateful to
president trump who recognizes that
wyoming has only one congressional
representative and we have to make it
count
cheney became one of the best known
members of congress this year as the
vice chair of the congressional
investigation into the events
surrounding the insurrection of january
6th 2021 as well as the various schemes
and falsehoods trump and his associates
hatched as he attempted to remain in
office after losing the election
but that didn't go over well with
wyoming voters 70 percent of whom voted
for trump over joe biden in 2020
despite her defeat many people in
wyoming and in washington d.c expect
cheney to run for president in 2024
using her reputation as a defender of
democracy who stood up to trump when
other republicans failed to do so
chaney did nothing to dispel those
expectations in her concession speech
this primary election is over
but now the real work begins
chaney's loss does not mean that she
will leave her post as vice chair of the
january 6th committee which will remain
active at least until january of next
year she has announced that hearings
will resume in september and says that
witnesses continue to come forward and
new evidence is pouring in rob reynolds
al jazeera jackson wyoming